This video is sponsored by war thunder.
Play war thunder for free and get a premium aircraft tank or ship and a
three-day counts. Upgrade as a bonus available on PCPs PS4,
an X-Box one more on them.
Unlikely,
likely the single most successful assassin in history were 19 year olds.
Gabriela Princip fired two shots in Sarajevo on June the 28th, 1914,
killing the air to the Austrian throne.
He set in motion events that would change the course of history. Uh,
South Slavic nationalist Princip sanctions would not only result in the creation
of a South Slav state Yugoslavia,
but in the fall of empires and the outbreak of world war one,
forget other assassins like John Wilkes booth or Lee Harvey Oswald compared to
Gavrilo Princip. Those guys were amateurs. Yes.
How much do most of us actually know about the teenager who started world war
one, born to a poor peasant family and the desolate mountains of Western Bosnia.
Princip seemed destined to leave no Mark on history, sickly,
small physically weak. His life was a world away from that of the imposing,
wealthy, powerful man that he killed. Yes,
it would be the unlikely meeting of these two figures that decided Europe's
destiny and known in life obscure in death.
This is the tale of a Gavrilo Princip and the assassin who changed the world.
It was the summer of 1894.
When Gavrilo Princip was born into a world of utter desolation,
his parents' home village, verbal,
I was little more than a Hamlet clinging to the side of an unforgiving mountain.
This was remote as to Bosnia, the place of Stony ground,
wild rivers and bitter, nighttime frosts,
a place so far from human civilization that locals knew it as Voco your Bina,
which translates as the place where wolves go to it was also a
place of biting poverty.
The Principia lived in a small house with a dirt floor upon which Maria Princip
gave birth to nine children, but only three survived. The boy's father.
Peter was a part-time Melman and full-time peasant working backbreaking hours
under a feudal system that forced him to give his crops away to remote
landlords.
So scans were signs of civilization in this empty lands that we don't even
know, give reala principally date of birth.
The municipal authorities recorded it as June the 13th, 1894.
While the local authorities entered it as the month of July,
it's actually something of a miracle that they bother to register it at all.
Princip was born so week that his father supposedly wrote him off.
It was only when a local Orthodox priest suggested that they named the child
after the Archangel Gabriel, that the boy's survival became the shirt,
whether that's true or not.
It does lead us nicely to a core part of princess backgrounds like their entire
village. The Prince ups were from the Orthodox faith in Bosnia's kaleidoscope of
ethnicities. That meant they were Bosnian Serbs as opposed Catholic Bosnian,
Croats or Muslim Bosniaks.
And just to confuse you a little bit more principally being Bosnian was a whole
different deal than him being purely Serbian by 1894,
the Serbs already had their own independent kingdom, the Bosnian Serbs,
or any of the Bosnians for that matter, they didn't,
it would be this fact more than any other that would turn young princess from a
peasant son into a violent radical.
[Inaudible].
So now we've established good, very low principally backgrounds.
We need to wind back the clock a little bit just enough to understand the
political tensions in play in Bosnia.
The twisted path that led to an independent Serbia runs a very not independent
Bosnia began back in the 14th century on June the 28th, 1389,
the expansionist superpower of its day,
the autumn and AMBA defeated the medieval Serbs at the battle of Kosovo,
opening up the Balcones for conquest and conquer.
They did the Ottomans would eventually Congo all the way to Vienna before
running out of steam, sadly for Constantinople,
all that mega conquering sends them running smack into the other superpower of
the day.
The Habsburgs Ruelas of Austria and long-time embers of the Holy Roman empire.
The Habsburgs were the Ottomans worst nightmare,
hardcore Catholics who loved a good old fashioned war over the next
few centuries Southeast Europe became an eternal battle ground.
Does the Habsburgs slowly push the Ottomans back for Serbs still smarting over
their 1389 defeat of Kosovo. This was all like, well, yay,
go Austria.
But while the Habsburgs spent centuries supporting Antietam and Serbs,
it wasn't because they were good neighbors in the 19th century.
The ultimate embar became known as the sick man of Europe estate. So weak,
the subs were able to gain defacto independence though.
Bosniak continued to smart under Turkish rule.
This change of fortunes had its peak in 1877,
that hip Serbia and Imperial Russia joined forces to give the Ottomans a
gigantic kick up the backside.
This effectively ended their grip on the Balkans.
It was party time in Belgrade with the tax out.
Serbia could get started with this plan to build a pan South Slavic state one,
including Bosnia. It was at this point.
So the Habsburgs made their change from allies to well,
total at the Congress of Berlin.
They took Bosnia over themselves for the Serbs.
This was a little like opening the front door,
expecting a good friend only for that friend to immediately seduce your mother
Belgrade was outraged.
They hadn't just fought a devastating war to see the Austro-Hungarians snatch
Bosnia, but what could tiny Cynthia and Randy do to stomp them in August, 1878,
Austrian troops marched into Bosnia.
Although the region remained a measure parts of the Ottoman empire. In reality,
it became an Austrian colony. On one hand. This meant staff like improved roads,
the first railways and trams and electric lighting for Sarajevo.
On the other hand,
I meant middy swapping one distant overlord for eight another.
The smoldering resentment that this entails would turn Bosnia into a powder keg.
When it finally exploded,
it would bring the Austro-Hungarian embar crashing down.
[Inaudible].
In the desolate mountains of Wolf Sachs land, younger reload,
Prince zip was having an utterly average childhood.
He helped his parents work the barren lands in his spare time.
He fished for trout in the gold mountain streams,
but there was one respect in which Prince sips,
early years were very far from average.
The boy utterly excelled at school in a time and place where illiteracy levels
stood at a staggering 88% principally taught himself, not just to read,
but to read a books that would make war and peace look like Clifford,
the big red dog in doing so. He discovered a whole other world in the cities.
The early 20th century was a time of great and frantic change.
There was automation, electricity, the earliest twinklings of mass production.
A world of speed,
energy transformation as Princip read about this boys from the nearby villages
were already heading to Sarajevo his older brother, yoga among them.
It was inevitable that the younger boy would follow him in 1907 age,
13 Principia, and his father set out to walk the 200 odd kilometers to Sarajevo.
Peter hadn't wanted the boy to go insisting that the family couldn't afford it.
But then Joe,
by now a successful small time timber merchant had offered to pay Princip
schooling fees, and the deal had been sealed. A few weeks later,
Princip was amidst the bustle and energy of Sarajevo ready to start a new life.
It was sheer coincidence that he arrived just as the mother of all crises
erupted. While principal had been learning to read relations between Austria,
Hungary and Serbia had been worsening in 1903,
a group of hotline nationalists had murdered Serbia's King and brought Peter
[inaudible] to power. [inaudible] had severed.
Servi has remaining ties with Austria and started cozying up to the end of his
rival rush out. But while this had strange things between the two States,
the big break came in 1908 that October the Habsburgs straight up annexed
Bosnia, although Austria had defacto ruled Bosnia for 30 years,
making it desert nanny sent to Europe to war Serbia was furious in
Belgrade. The move was seen as the first step towards an Austrian takeover.
In the end,
the crisis was resolved when Germany gave Austria its unconditional backing.
The only powers capable of taking on Berlin,
France and Britain didn't care enough about Bosnia to start a war while the one
power that did cap Russia was far too weak to tango with Germany.
So the crisis passed at least on the world stage,
but on the ground in Serbia and Bosnia,
it became a catalyst in the wake of the annexation.
The first shoots of Bosnian nationalism began to emerge people.
Who'd never considered the question before became champions of an independent
Bosnia as this wave of revolutionary anger swept through the coffee houses and
through the bazaars and schools,
Cabrillo Princip found himself getting swept hops to the boy,
began to devour anarchist literature,
a radical move at a time when anarchists were assassinating Kings presidents and
empresses he fell in love with two like-minded Bosnian Serbs near Dayco
[inaudible] and [inaudible] together. The three joints protests daubed,
Andy Hapsburg graffiti on walls. Finally in 1910,
the new nationalist movement got its first martyr on June the 15th Bosnians
bogged down Zaria fired five shots at Bosnia's military governor on a bridge
near Prince sips, home,
all five shots missed and Zarit she used the sixth bullet to commit suicide.
When Prince Princip rushed outside to see the commotion,
he saw the stones still stained with [inaudible] blood. It was a gory sight,
but it was something else to the teenage Princip too.
It was a major inspiration.
Now just before we get into what he does with that inspiration. I mean,
you already know, but we're going to tell the story.
Let me tell you about today's fantastic sponsor war thunder.
Thunder is a realistic free to play military vehicle combat game.
It's available on PC PS4 and Xbox one, but you only need one of those,
no need to purchase as well. Just download and you get to playing in this game.
There are over 1,500 to Starkey,
accurate vehicles all the way from 1920 to the 1990s Catholic Gold's
incredibly detailed and you can see the rule of the physics has really been
sweated over. It's really very good. Plus the sound is good too. And look,
you can just jump in for a quick arcade game useful if you don't have much time
or you can play realistic and go for the more challenging stuff or if you're a
bit hardcore, there's always simulator numbers. You know,
I've got no idea how that is because I don't like getting my whipped over and
over again. So John was on the battlefield today.
There is a link below doing that,
supports the show and it also gets you a free premium tank ship or an aircraft
in three days of premium time as a bonus for registering.
And let's get back to the video.
1811,
the general feeling of revolution had started to coalesce into specific groups
in Serbia, proper the black hands,
cropped up as a pet project of one of the 1983 regicides and current heads of
Serbian intelligence and man known as APIs over in Bosnia.
The key group was Mada Bosnia or young Bosnia possibly created with help from
the black hands.
Lot of balls in his goal was to free Bosnia from the Habsburgs and join it in
union with Serbia.
Naturally there's appealed hugely to Bosnian Serbs like Prince it by now,
Prince SIPPET almost given up on school. His entire mind,
all his energies were devoted to mourning the plight of Serbia and building his
hatred towards Austria in today's terms would say that it'd become radicalized
Prince.
It finally broke from regular life in 1912 that year he was kicked out of school
for attending an anti [inaudible] rally and some versions after threatening pro
Imperial classmates with NACO dusters angry and directionless Princip wanted to
leave, sorry,
over behind to go to Serbia and help fight the good fight he was about to get
his chomps an October 12,
the first Balkan war erupted hitting the kingdoms of Serbia, Bulgaria,
Greece in Montenegro against the decaying ultimate state.
It was the best Johns yet kicks the Turks out of the Balkins for good,
like a radicalized Dean going to Syria.
Princip dropped everything and walked the 280 kilometers to Serbia to volunteer.
Supposedly the first thing he did upon crossing the border was to fall to his
knees and kissed the Serbian soil. If that tail is true,
that it must've made what came next, seem older, worse. Oh,
in the winter of 1912 was a wash with offices trying to recruit more trips,
but wasn't principal easily tried to join up.
His tiny frame and sickly complexion got, gotten,
literally laughed out of recruitment centers.
And so it was that Cabrillo Princip missed his great chance to be a part of the
story of Serbia.
What happened next is hazy because not much documentation exists and historians
have wildly different theories,
but it's generally agreed that Princip stayed on in Belgrade's joined once again
by his radicalized friends Cabrina Vich and grab us in some versions.
Princip was forced to sleep rough in doorways and others.
He was the one supporting the others,
our small stipends from his parents yet they still had enough money to submerge
themselves in the radical coffee house scene scene where Bosnian Serbs meant to
plot revolution there.
The three boys soon came to the attention of Belgrade's ultra nationalist
groups. How exactly this happens is up for debate of the two recent best English
language books on the subject, Tim bushes, the trigger and Christopher clocks,
the sleepwalkers butcher's book claims Princip self radicalized.
While clock's book says that he was groomed by the black hands,
either way there's 1913 wins on principle.
Thoughts turns more and more towards violence action in no time at all,
those thoughts would stop being mere thoughts and it's become a terrifying
reality.
[Inaudible].
First of all, Korean war was going so well for Serbia.
That Austria started to panic in Bosnia.
The military governor declared a state of emergency closed Serb institutions,
suspended the courts and shut the Bosnian parliaments up in Austria,
proper the army chief of staff on Hudson Dorf started stomping around and
demanding and invasion of Servier. Ironically,
the man who stopped this was principally future victim Archduke Franz Ferdinand
Ferdinand was the biggest dove. The VNS court,
the lone voice agitating against starting a major war in the Balkans come
some in 1913,
the Ottomans had been all but driven out of the Balkans and Serbian territory in
majorly expanded for principle in his mates.
This was all the evidence they needed,
that the impossible would soon happen that the peninsula would seem to be free
of Imperial powers that winds up Princip stayed with his parents in Chile
[inaudible] but when he returns to Belgrade in March,
it was didn't use that hit him like a haymaker to the groin all over the Serbian
capital headlines bled from newspapers, Franz Virgin, and was going to visit,
sorry, over that summer, his chosen date, June the 28th, as you may recall,
June 28th was the battle of Kosovo, a date. So emotionally charged for Serbs,
almost like combining July the fourth with nine 11.
Now imagine that you heard that nine 11, seven,
four was going to be marked by a genetic crossbreed of a solid bin,
Lauden and King George, the third stomping around his New York,
declaring jihad and trying to tax people without representation.
That that's how Bosnian Serbs felt about friends.
Virgin Nan's visit to Sarajevo all that spring room as swelled that Ferdinand's
visit was meant to cover up a surprise Austrian attack on Saudia as the room is
intensifying, give relief Princip made an important decision.
He decided to kill the Archduke. What did he and his magisterial book,
the sleep walk as Christopher Clark suggests that the plot didn't originate with
Princip, but with APIs,
the shadow we had of Serbian intelligence in this telling app is new.
The dovish Ferdinand wanted to make peace with his Balkan subjects.
Maybe even elevating them to co-equals in his empire.
Since this would destroy Belgrade's hopes of an independent Bosnia APIs don't
wreck the black hand to recruit an assassin and the black hands,
they chose principally that spring,
Princip cupboard Vich and grab his practice target shooting in Belgrade.
By now the Serbian capital was frothing without her age at the Archduke
newspapers called him a dog and his wife, a filthier Bohemian hall.
It was amid this climates of hatred that six small bombs and four revolvers went
missing from the Serbian state hospital. On may the 27th,
they were passed a Grillo Princip four nights later,
the black hands underground railway smuggled,
principally his friends across the Bosnian border.
And as work of Bosnians was helped.
All three conspirators reached Sarajevo where they hooked up with a local cell
from nada Bosner. As June dawned in the Capitol,
Princip spent his nights at the grave of bogged down Zaria meditating on what
needs to be done. And in a few short kilometers away,
Franz Ferdinand and his wife,
Sophie were staying at a Bosnian retreat and aware of Prince sips plans and
perhaps the creepiest moments of this entire tale.
They made a Candescent trip to Sarajevo on June the 25th to wonder around the
bizarre unknown to them. Princip just happened to be there.
The teenage boy trailed them like a shadow studying their every move.
It was the first time Princip had ever seen the Austrian act closeup.
Sadly for Europe, it was not going to be the last
Yes, fascination crowds.
Thronged alongside Sarajevo's Myakka river waiting for a glimpse of the
raw couple Prince up and disco conspirators space themselves out along the
routes. Each carried a weapon of all moral alluded revolver.
They also carried small pockets of Sinai. This was to be a one-way trip,
the chance to become martyrs like Bob Dan's area.
It's the day before it had been rainy and cool with poor visibility.
But as Princip took up his position that morning, it was under a bright sun.
It's possible. Principally wondered where all the gods were.
State visits were usually accompanied by a show of military minds.
But today there was no security. Finally, in the distance,
the boy spotted his target just by being the assassin.
Everyone remembers Prince.
It wasn't actually the first in line that's on the fellows were young Bosniak
you froze able to fire his revolver seconds came principally radical friends can
print of it's.
Unlike the Bosniak Bryn of its prime does bomb and threw it in Ferdinand's car.
But the driver saw it and sped up and the bomb exploded beneath the car behind
them in grimly,
humorous moments of it swallowed his cyanide and trying to hurt himself into the
mill Yaka.
But the poison was so weak that it only scorched his throat and the river was so
low. He simply went crashing into the bank. At this stage,
the assassination was closer to Mr. Bean was on a terrorist attack by
Wright's friends. Ferdinand's should have fled the city. Instead.
Ferdinand dude stopped his guard to tend to the wounded soccer of being
arrested. And I said, these fateful words,
that fellow is clearly insane. Let us proceed. Meanwhile,
I could read a principal, heard the bomb, go off,
heard the screams and assumes the assassination that succeeded.
He was running towards the commotion feeling of triumph already washing over
him. When he saw the Archduke go sailing past in his car, completely unharmed.
We can only imagine what princess thought moment,
but we're guessing it was the Serbians equivalence of Oh.
But it turns out that yeah,
[inaudible] with smiling on the teenager that day as principal loitered on the
corner of friends, Joseph streets,
and know the story about him stopping for a sandwich simply isn't true.
Archduke Ferdinand was in San Diego city hall demanding to be taken,
to see the wounded local officials trying to talk him out of it and was adamant.
So it was decided that they would change the roots just in case other assassins
were lacking. But no one thought to tell the driver.
And so it was that instead of carrying on, along the river,
the car carrying Ferdinand swung onto friends, Joseph street,
right next to freeload Princip,
incredibly this wasn't the final thing they had to do wrong to seal Ferdinand's
fate Princip was so astounded to see the converts in theirs.
It wouldn't have had a chance in hell of getting a shot off the driver.
It just kept on driving, but someone shouted, Hey, you go in the wrong way.
So the drivers stopped right there just to meet us from Prince sip.
As principally to told it, time seemed to slow down. He tried to use his bomb,
but it got caught in his coat. So instead he pulled out his revolver,
ran to the car and pointed it at the couple. According to his testimony,
he locked eyes with the Archduke security man who blinked stupidly.
Then there was a crack followed by another sharp crack.
Then the car was speeding away. As a crowd, fell on, Prince kicking him,
punching him, trying to kill him in the middle of this.
Malai Princip tried to shoot himself only to feel the gun torn out of his hands.
He went for a cyanide, but it was kicked away. Give reload.
Princip was very nearly lynched that morning.
His life only saved when the policemen managed to arrest him at that moment,
Prince still didn't know he'd been successful.
He still didn't know that one of his two bullets had passed through your
friend's Ferdinand's neck severing his artery.
He didn't know that the other had Guild.
Sophie leaving nothing of the Royal couple shortly after 11:00 AM.
The out to the Austrian empire was pronounced dead.
As bells began ringing across Sarajevo in morning,
it's likely Prinsep felt some satisfaction had done the deed.
The Archduke was dead from now on nothing would ever be the same again.
[inaudible]
Whole books have been received about how this one assassination sparks.
One of the deadliest conflicts in human history.
The super basic version is that Austria Hungary decided that the Serbian state
had ordered the killing and invaded the Balkan kingdom. One by one, this trips,
the switch on a complex series of alliances.
Each bringing some new ally into the fight until the entire continent was pulled
into what should have been a minor war. And while you know the rest of all,
why the trenches, the gas,
the millions upon millions dead by the time Princip was put on trial.
On October the 17th, the sorter was already underway.
The trial of gorilla Princip is notable for two things.
One is that it gave him a chance to declare his motives.
Unlike the popular image of Princip as a Serbian nationalist,
the young man said he was a South Slavic dedicated to kicking the Austrians out
of the Balkans. So all South Slavs could join into a single state.
The second is just how close Princip came to getting the death penalty.
Remember at the very start when we said no one knew if Prince had been born on
the 13th of June or the 13th of July, 1894. Well in Austria,
the death penalty couldn't be applied to anyone under the age of 20.
When they committed a crime. If principal had been born on June 13th, it hang.
If the real date was July 13th, it only go to prison. In the end,
the court accepted the later date.
Prince had been 19 when it shot Franz Ferdinand,
executing him would have been against the law on October the 28th of 1914 Prince
up and his co-conspirators were found guilty while most of his compatriots would
hang.
Princip was given 20 years in Terrazine fortress in modern day Czech Republic,
but don't go thinking he got off lightly.
The Austrians wanted Prince up to suffer.
He was kept in isolation and ordered to go without food for one day,
every month by now, Princip was already showing signs of the tuberculosis,
eating away at his system.
Now one doubted that the Sickler young man would be dead before the end of the
sentence. The principal was dead. Even before the end of the war,
give you a Prince that died on April the 28th, 1918 age, just 23,
less than seven months later in November, 1918,
Austria Hungary completely collapsed going the same way as both Imperial Russia
and the ultimate empire.
By now around 20 billion people had died as the war ended.
Bosnia joined with Serbia, Croatia, Slovenia,
and Montenegro into a single state. Two years later,
Principia remains work returned to Surrey over where he was buried as a hero,
but principally reputation didn't stay settled for long.
During the post-war decades.
When Prince dream of a United South Slav nation was an actual real thing called
Yugoslavia. The teenager assassin was celebrated as an icon,
but then Yugoslavia collapsed in the early 1990s.
And Princip came to be seen as a dangerous Serb nationalist,
a forerunner of monsters like Ratko Nottage in Sarajevo.
The Memorial to him was destroyed during the Bosnian war.
By the time the dust settled on that gruesome conflict,
local views on Principia basically depended on ethnicity ironically for a pan
South Slav nationalist. Today,
it's only the Serbs who celebrate celebrating the Bosniaks and Crow outs mostly
regarding as a terrorist, whatever your personal thoughts on Princip though.
There's no doubting that he's a significant figure.
Although we like to pretend otherwise there was nothing inevitable about world
war one shore European war was coming,
but it was where the continents shifting alliances lay at that precise moment
that made it so big.
And so deadly push the trigger back a few years to when Russia was weaker or
forward a few years to when the dovish Franz Ferdinand would have been on the
Austrian throne. And that war might've looked really, really different.
Sometimes history changes slowly.
Sometimes it turns on great moments for gorilla Princip,
the penniless teenage boy from a peasant backgrounds.
It was his destiny to stand at the heart of one of those great moments to be the
axis around which the future briefly turned as he fired two shots that hot July
day. So many decades ago,
his moment in the spotlight of history may have only lasted a handful of
seconds,
but it was more significant than the lives of Kings and presidents who spend
decades there for that reason, if no other is short,
life deserves to be remembered. So I do hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Also please do consider supporting our fantastic sponsor Wharf hundr.
There is a link to them below.
Thank you for watching
[inaudible].